hey guys in this video we are bringing
you first official stills for the hbo's
upcoming game of thrones prequel series
house of the dragon
which is about a targaryen civil war
known as the dance of the dragons
that tore westeros apart over 100 years
before the original series
although production on house of the
dragon is still very much in progress
audience is getting a gift with official
images of the series main characters
here are some close-up shots of its main
characters
first we have the sea snake himself
actor steve tucson as lord cordless
valerian with silver dreadlocks
this series is about a targaryen civil
war that breaks out when king viserys
dies
and his children rhaenyra and aegon
start a war for the iron throne
both claimants to the iron throne have
allies and the most prominent on
rhaenyra's side is scoreless valerian
the head of an ancient valyrian house
with a powerful navy
valerians had for centuries remained the
oldest
and closest allies of the targaryens and
in this war they chose to fight for
rhaenyra
during the conquest it was valyrian
ships that carried aegon's soldiers
across the blackwater bay
and later form the greater part of the
royal fleet
the most famous and strongest valerian
to ever live is also one of the main
characters in the upcoming
house of the dragon show corliss
valerian
known as the sea snake is a fable the
lord of the tides during targaryen's
civil war
master of driftmark and the head of
house valerian
house valerian much like house targaryen
is of valyrian descent
and its members often have valyrian
features
such as silver hair purple eyes but
their skin is different
because unlike targaryens they have
married outside
their own family the sea snake is the
husband of princess
rhaenys targaryen the queen who never
was king viserys
cousin who especially loves rhaenyra
during the dance of the dragons corliss
becomes handed to queen rhaenyra
targaryen
who is his niece and daughter-in-law as
she marries his son
the sea snake's life before the dance of
the dragons was just as exciting
as a matter of fact he is getting his
own game of thrones prequel show
named nine voyages corliss is also a
good friend of rhaenyra's uncle soon to
become
husband prince daemon lord corliss and
his fleet fought alongside prince daemon
targaryen during the war for the
stepstones
when daemon declared himself the king of
the stepstones in the narrow sea
corliss placed the crown on the new
king's head
lord corliss valerian sits on the black
council during the civil war known as
the dance of the dragons
he is the greatest lord to pledge his
strength to the cause of queen rhaenyra
targaryen
who was opposed by her half-brother king
aegon the second targaryen
more than half of rhaenyra's army is
made up of men sworn to house valerian
corliss's fleet also gives the black
superiority at sea
the lord bought him a salty gear
pressured the princess to fly from
dragonstone to king's landing at once
and reduce the city to ash and bone with
her dragon
corliss demanded to know how that would
serve them
telling him we want to rule the city not
burn it to the ground
which tells you much and more about his
character later in the story
corliss even saves most of the great
families of westeros
by sending envoys to the lannisters
baratheons and hightowers
who had been aegon the second's main
supporters suing for peace preventing
the wolf of winterfell
craig and stark from marching on them as
he wanted to continue the war until all
rhaenyra's enemies were destroyed
corliss is going to be one of your
favorite characters in house of the
dragon
from queen rhaenyra's allies we go to
her enemies
queen elizand and her father seroto
hightower
rhaenyra is the chosen heir of her
father king viserys
and totally expects to be a queen when
he dies
but has all good plans this one fails as
well
because she has a rival in the form of
her dad's second wife felix and
hightower
and her father otto hightower the hand
of the king
instead of rhaenyra they prefer that
alison's first son by the king
aegon targaryen take the iron throne
when king viserys passes
alicent is of course wearing a green
dress the color of her house
and of her factions that support her son
aegon
while her father otto is wearing the
hand of the kingpin
as at this time king viserys is still
alive and he is his hand
although he held that same position
before king viserys
and will vary it after him alison
hightower is a member of house hightower
who becomes the second wife to king
viserys the first targaryen
and therefore a queen of the targaryen
dynasty she's a daughter of seroto
hightower
who had been the hand of the king to
jaehaerys the first viserys the first
and later his grandson aegon ii
she is the mother of king aegon ii queen
hilina
prince aymond and prince daeron ali sent
hightower is in many ways the true
leader of fagon the second's faction
during the dance of the dragons alison's
father
otto hightower had been the hand of the
king in the last few years
of the long reign of king jaehaerys the
first targaryen
in 101ac oto brought the young alicent
to the royal court
where she cared for the aging king
jaehaerys eventually died in 103ac
while he sent was reading to him and was
succeeded by his grandson viserys the
first
alison stayed at court as her father
continued to occupy the position as the
hand under jaehaerys's grandson and
successor
king viserys the first targaryen already
early in the reign of viserys sir otto
and prince daemon targaryen were at odds
with each other
and the court full mushroom has
suggested that the quarrel between the
two men began when daemon deflowered
ellison
the truths of these tales have never
been uncovered visser is the first first
queen
emma rayne only produced one living
child before her death
a daughter rhaenyra in the years that
followed alice and caught the eye of
king viserys the first targaryen
and wizard chose alicent as his second
wife they married in 106
ac despite the whispers of people who
believed that the hand had risen above
himself
some doubt retell his sense virtue as
rumors began circling that she had given
her maidenhead to prince daemon
and had later even slept with king
viserys while queen emma was still
alive the notorious mushroom suggested
that alison had been intimate with the
late jaehaerys as well
nonetheless alicent was wed to his heirs
at first young rainer and ellison got
along well
but the rift grew between them as soon
as allison produced her own children for
viserys the first
and clearly wanting them to succeed to
the throne instead of her
ellie sent bore wizards the first four
children aegon the second
aemon the one eye there on the daring
and helina who became the sister wife of
fagon ii
over the years of viserys since the
first terrain despite his best efforts
a better rivalry grew between alice sent
and rhaenyra at court
as well as between their rival factions
of supporters
in 111ac a great tourney was held at
king's landing
on the 5th anniversary of the king's
marriage to queen ellison
at the opening feast alison wore a green
gown while princess rhaenyra dressed in
targaryen red
and black soon afterward their
respective followers started dressing in
similar colors and styles
to display their political allegiance
rhaenyra's faction the princess's
followers wore black clothing
in dallas satisfaction the queen's
followers wore green clothing
ultimately this inspired the nicknames
for the two factions the blacks and the
greens
the blacks rhaenyra supporters included
the stark stallis
rayne starlis and valerians among others
while the green salads and supporters
included the high towers and the
lannisters
among others the baratheons started out
as blacks
but switched to the greens when the
civil war began while the tyrells may
have been greens at first
but during the civil war itself declared
themselves neutral
bizarre is the first publicly and
repeatedly made the great lords of the
realms fair oaths that rhaenyra would
succeed him on the iron throne
as the first ruling queen but when he
dies his wife
alicent and his hand seroto will be the
first to support aegon ii
who is their own kin and not only
support
but stay jakku last but not the least we
have this close-up shot of rhaenyra and
daemon targaryen themselves
the two key figures of this series
daemon is the younger brother of king
viserys the first targaryen
while rhaenyra is his daughter that
makes them uncle and ease who will
eventually also become husband and wife
as well
because this is the game of thrones
universe and they are the true
targaryens after all
let me know in the comments down below
if you like the dragon scales on demon's
arms and rhaenyra's dress
rhinera targaryen king viserys's chosen
heir
a dragon rider who grew up expecting to
become the first ruling queen of
westeros
king viserys's chosen heir a dragon
rider who grew up expecting to become
the first ruling queen of westeros
princess rhaenyra targaryen cheered as
the realm's delight
when she was young and later called the
half-year queen
was the first born child of king viserys
the first targaryen
rhaenyra was king viserys as the first
only living child
by his first wife queen emma of house
sarin
at the age of eight she was made her
father's heir
and grew up expecting to become the
first ruling queen of westeros
rhaenyra was a dragon rider whose mount
was xyrex
rhaenyra had her family's valyrian looks
varying her silver gold hair in a long
braid in the manner
of queen with zenia targaryen beautiful
as a child rhaenyra was later declared
by her uncle
later husband and the man who is
standing beside her in these photos
prince daemon targaryen to be the most
beautiful maiden
in all the seven kingdoms daemon
targaryen is also a key
figure from this time period and is
george r martin's favorite
targaryen daemon was the most
controversial man of his lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in
equal measure
there was never a man so loved and so
reviled and at the same time as he was
during the dance of the dragons as the
husband of his niece rhaenyra he
supported his wife's claim
and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in nestorous
at a time of her father's death rhaenyra
was on dragonstone evading the birth of
her child
the green sinking's landing ensured that
the news of viserys's death did not
reach her until her own supporters in
the red keep were dead
or imprisoned and dagon ii's coronation
had already occurred
this began a devastating civil war that
tore apart the seven kingdoms
known as the dance of the dragons as it
was the only war
in which both sides had the dragon
riders well there you have it guys first
official stills for the upcoming game of
thrones prequel series house of the
dragon that will air in 2022
stay tuned for more i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
give it a big thumbs up and i hope to
see you in the next one
peace